we have got a great underwear Aaron
Andrews and Tom Bergeron returned to
Dancing with the Stars I want to take a
moment to say
dad loved this young never missed an
episode and I would like to think that
somewhere he didn't
it's been a rough few months for hosts
Tom Bergeron and Erin Andrews with both
Bergeron's parents passing an andrews
court battle coming to a close but on
Monday night's season 22 premiere the
pair seemed in great spirits what an
awesome way to start off the night Erin
even took to Instagram last week to
share with fans her excitement about
returning to the ballroom writing quote
can't wait to be standing next to Tom
Bergeron next Monday night much needed
hashtag ballroom therapy for both of us
the 60 year old host sweetly replied the
feeling is mutual eats he caught up with
the Dancing with the Stars judge Carrie
Ann Inaba after the taping Monday where
she praised Andrews for her return amid
personal turmoil
I love Erin she's so strong and I'm so
proud of her I was really impressed with
it and I'm really proud of her